[Música]
meu nome é jessica ti eu tenho 26 anos e
eu vou contar pra vocês como através do
concurso de beleza eu decidir com a
carreira acadêmica eu queria seguir bom
dá pra ver que a sua louca né do
concurso de beleza culpa disso a maioria
deles da minha mãe né que fez eu
participei de quase todos por livre e
espontânea pressão quando foi em 2005 eu
mudei para os estados unidos com a minha
família meu pai pra trabalhar então foi
a minha mãe todo mundo
especificamente em 2009 a minha mãe
descobriu que existe um concurso que
elegerá a brasileira mais bonita do
estado de massachusetts e ela ficou
louca que toda mulher que a alta não
posso jogador de basquete já tem que ser
modelo né
então todo mundo fala minha mãe porque
ela tem um modelo ela tem que participar
ela ficou falando isso na minha cabeça o
tempo todo ea gente não tinha dinheiro
nem para pagar a inscrição do concurso a
ela dinheiro emprestado da minha avó me
colocou no concurso de beleza e aí fomos
eu com esse cabelo enorme mas talvez
tendência na época 2009
a gente foi para o concurso de beleza e
aí é só uma fotinha bem antes de começar
e eu não esqueço de uma coisa que ela me
falou nesse dia que é engraçado que eu
nem ela lembra que ela tá ali ela me
chamou no canto falou assim ah olha e
sabe que a mamãe te ama que você é linda
né
é pra toda a manhã a gente é lindo mas
tenho a minha dali que ela não chamarem
ela em quarto lugar não chamarem ela em
terceiro não chamarem no segundo você
perdeu a nota legal que eu tô aqui
pronta pra vim passear é ela foi não
porque eu tenho certeza que ela vai
ficar entre as três finalistas foi
tratar todo mundo esperando eu vou ter
que desfilar nem aí fui eleito minha
parte eu acho que esse concurso de uma
tríade candidata só chegou chamou todo
mundo no palco e aí quarta candidata a
nada da menina eu a gente tem que fingir
que está tudo bem está tudo sob controle
a terceira candidata a nada da menina
segundo a candidata nada da menina aí
uma questão não foi desta vez
e aí por incrível que pareça me chamaram
como a vencedora do concurso eu nunca
esperava que minha mãe né tá ligado nem
ela esperava que ocorresse com custo e
eu fui eleita brasileira mais bonita
de massachusetts depois fui para o
nacional mas aí eu só fiquei entre as 15
finalistas
não ganhei e foi ótimo foi em 2009 mas
aí chegou 2010
esse foi o final de 2009 a escala para
outubro quando em 2010 de janeiro e
chamei para conversar meu pai falou ó
lembra aquele combinado que a gente
entre estados unidos que a gente ficar
um ano eu quero embora e eu quero ir
porque eu quero fazer meu terceiro
colegial brasil andam mas você tem que
ficar aqui você tem um reinado de miss
não vai querer pegar o chapéu de lã
risco jogar pra cima
então não quero ir embora porque eu
quero me formar com 22 anos eu não quero
que as minhas amigas passe na frente e
isso e isso aconteça uma das coisas que
eu me arrependi poderia ter curtido o
meu reinado de mingo a poderia ter
jogado um papel bem pra cima risco mas
não quis ir embora quando a viu sozinha
porque eu queria fazer uma terceira
coisa para entrar na faculdade e aí vim
fiquei um tempo morando com a minha tia
quando chegou dezembro foi a hora de
escolher quem quer fazer da minha vida
com 17 anos eu não sabia nem se eu
estava com fome ou não eu tinha que me
inscrever no vestibular
e aí eu ficava escutando toda aquela
opinião pessoal e um elenco que me
inscrevi no vestibular que dão lhe um
dia antes de fechar e vai fazer o quê
direito que é um leque que ela foi
advogada e juíza você criei e todo mundo
se dá bem com direito então eu fui bater
em direito é uma foto linda do meu trote
olha que legal
mais uma vez na vida que eu nunca mais
acontecer e aí eu entrei na faculdade
cheguei no primeiro dia de aula que o
professor de terno social arrumado mas
vou falar aquela coisa difícil de lei de
política de governo e eu falei que eu
estou fazendo aqui
eu não gosto disso e agora como eu vou
falar com meus pais que o destaque
e eu lembro que no primeiro semestre
eram oito matérias 19 peguei quatro
dependências porque eu não queria ficar
ali eu ir pra aula ea minha mãe como ela
não quer faixa ela falou cheta descobrir
que tem um miserável que é participar
foi a não lá vem você de novo me fiando
em outro concurso beleza ela jogava não
vamos que tem vai ser legal é que na
cidade que o outro a gente pode por em
boston
quem pegar uma hora de estrada só para
participar do concurso que também vá à
informa que o concurso tinha cinco
candidatas e aí eu fiquei morrendo de
vergonha a gente pelo amor de deus com
esse monte de gente aqui imagina perder
é claro que a gente vai pensando nisso
eu perder
e aí eu fui
e acabei sendo eleita a miss uberaba de
e aí eu sabia que a próxima etapa é
puxada que era minas gerais e que não ia
ter só cinco candidatas enfrenta 82
candidatas neste concurso e eu sabia que
é barra pesada porque dali eu ia pro
brasil
e aí há um concurso em fazer na época na
band eles escolheram dessas 32 20
candidatas nós vamos para belo horizonte
para uma seletiva chegou na seletiva
eles escolheram só finco e aí eu fiquei
entre as cinco candidatas com uns 15
quilos mais magra e os meninos e eu
lembro quando acabou isso o pessoal da
band um agente no canto e falou assim
olha meninas trocam de roupa que agora a
gente vai pra banco central vivo no
programa e lá a gente vai decidir quem
vai ganhar o mesmo gerais foi porque
nunca o lima televisão nunca foi no
estúdio né ea gente foi deu tudo certo e
eu fiquei encantada quando entrei
naquela já foi para o meu deus é isso
que eu amo que um lugar legal tv o
programa entrou no ar o pessoal fazendo
a contagem por tudo ótimo a irmã da
vítima para cada volta semana que vem em
fazer um evento e vai anunciar quem são
a quem é quem o título e eu voltei e
acabei sendo eleita a miss minas gerais
de 2012 e aí nessa hora eu fiquei
sabendo que realmente eu tinha muita
coisa pela frente porque eu tinha que
cumprir toda agenda do concurso eu tinha
todo esse tempo quase a cada 15 dias na
band minas em belo horizonte
e aí eu pensei faculdade não vai dar
agora né então eu tentei conversar com o
meu pai ea minha mãe toda empolgada
quando falar então vamos ter que ficar
15 dias confinados confinada no miss
brasil
não perdemos a aula que taxou trancar
agora pode trancar em todo mundo foi o
passo eu gravei aí tranquei a faculdade
e foi premiada no concurso miss brasil
fiquei lá confinado em fortaleza por 15
dias uma mulher maravilhosa e esta é uma
fotinha demandado eu não fiquei em
segundo lugar todo macho quem tem um
lugar porque justamente no meu ano eles
acharam que seria legal mudar a ordem do
concurso nunca mais aconteceu só meu ano
eles falaram que não dá visibilidade
para quem ficar em segundo lugar então
que eles vão trocar a ordem é chamar
primeiro e segundo lugar e depois ia
ficar primeiro terceiro e aí ficou ea
gabriela marta que foi eleita miss
brasil deste ano a gente amiga até hoje
tem validade até tem mas a gente amiga
até hoje
e aí depois que passou com custo
eu falei bom já que eu tranquei a
faculdade na final de ano eu vou tirar
esse ano pra colher os frutos então
trabalhei bastante e muita foto evento
em vários media para belo horizonte
tempo todo participada que o dia inteiro
naqueles programas da band ao vivo eu
achava o máximo ficar o dia inteiro
sentado esperando entrar no ar e foi
muito bom até que chegou na band me
ligou e falou agosto de 2013 vai passar
sua coroa próxima national no coração na
hora
e aí foi quando pensei 'bom agora é
preciso voltar a estudar e tirar um ano
de férias na hora de decidir que eu
queria fazer da minha vida
e aí eu fui e pensando sem saber ainda
eu já gostava de jornalismo e ficava
pensando em fazer jornalismo fazer o quê
nem achava que tem que mudar para belo
horizonte vai ter pra algum lugar e aí
eu fui pra minha mãe que eu queria ser
designer a hiop pedir interior do
interior e aí ela falou tá mesmo é um
técnico que quiser fazer a cobertura e
eu fui falar em nossa aqui ideia
brilhante e até a foto minha
quando ainda tinha dedos nessa época eu
acho que é o primeiro semetre
arquitetura né eu não tinha esmalte eu
tinha cola no dedo e foi na arquitetura
que eu descobri que o lapso não serve
nem pra você e colorir a apple tem que
chegar lá tem placar aponta dele ficaram
várias horas lá colorido com seu dedo
até da bola e fica lindo a planta que
acabou e que joga fora e guardou eu
queria matar eu odiava curso mas eu
falei 'bom eu vou seguir é mais linda
como eu vou pegar meu pai pra minha mãe
eu falar e então não estou gostando de
novo desse custo
mas não eu tenho eu estudava o pé não
era um direito que eu deixei levar eu ia
e aí um belo dia o josé alonso que é o
dono do miss terra brasil me ligou e
falou oit então eu tenho uma franquia do
miss terra brasil só que eu não tô
fazendo mais do concurso
eu preciso mandar brasileira para a
outra vai representar o brasil no
concurso miss terra que é um concurso
ambiental que a gente faz planta árvores
fica tudo voltar no meio ambiente tem
uma causa que taxa foi atá na alta com o
tempo de 24 dias
oba ah eu falei comentei com a minha mãe
foi bom eu acho que eu tentei nem eu vou
lá na secretaria do curso né
vou conversar
vou ver se dá pra faltar né torcendo que
não dá aí ele falou que realmente não
dava que 24 dias eram mês de aula num
impossível
e aí eu fui pra outra o concurso claro
não ia deixar de enxergar lá eu concorri
com mais entre 10 candidatos eu acho que
tinha e eu fiquei com o título de quarto
lugar que é primeiro em terra depois de
encerrar minha terra água e externa fogo
que é o meu eu acabei ficando até mais
um pouquinho lá pt cumpre agenda porque
eu tinha vencido é vencido neve está
entre as quatro ganhei o concurso
aí voltei da viu foi bom e agora né eu
tô aqui de novo era dezembro e eu
preocupado que eu ia fazer da vida já
estava com 22 22 e 23 anos
e aí eu falei deixa passar o final do
ano e no final do ano acabei conhecendo
meu marido e quando foi no começo de
fevereiro por aí eu decidi que ia para
são paulo
eu falei a gente não fala é que acham
que seu modelo então é uma pressão
quando você modelo daí depois eu decido
que eu quero fazer da minha vida e assim
eu fui e foi ótimo eu saí porque foi
nosso divisor de água eu vi que
realmente não era o que eu queria fazer
a minha vida não queria ser modelo
eu respeito quem pilota acho legal mas
não tem um produto entrava lá estava
muda e sai calada era 2 clipe
depois a gente liga pra te falar você
foi selecionada nunca ligavam nem
falavam nada e todo mundo como eu fui me
sempre quis escutar o que tinha pra
falar então eu falo a gente isso me
incomoda não é isso que eu quero e
começando com meu marido ele falou e aí
mas que você tem vontade de fazer a sua
vida e eu sem pensar falei eu queria
trabalhar em televisão queria ser
jornalista e apresentador de tv
então pronto vai foi nossa quem falou
isso pra mim é pronto vai pra a eu falei
não esperar e provar e que tem ataque
outra emissora que tempo a gente mas
acho que são paulo quem vai querer nem
eu trabalho na televisão também já
tentou então vai à mtv no vestibular e
crente que ia passar e eu acabei
passando e hoje eu faço jornalismo na
parte da manhã e na parte da tarde o
faça um curso técnico no senac para
apresentadora de tv e esse semestre tem
sido bem puxado mas é uma coisa que eu
amo assim em todo meu coração é uma
coisa que todo mundo
feliz realizada ea mensagem que eu
queria passar aqui pra vocês hoje não é
só pra você fazer o sistema porque o
clichê falar isso não fala disso
apesar que quando você faz o que você
ama você tem muito sucesso naquilo né
mas é a mensagem que eu quero falar para
vocês sobre esse texto que acaba aqui na
sociedade tem muito padrões aí você
precisa formar com 22 anos você precisa
casar conta do agora acabei de casar ou
não pergunta que você mãe tá na hora a
gente tem que viver o nosso momento
respeitar a nossa hora porque só assim a
gente vai ser feliz e assim pra quem
aluno pra quem é pai que é professor de
encerrar eu não vejo os cursos que eu
passei como o arrependimento e já faz
parte não é um erro
o papo foi apresado eu vi que não que eu
não gostava daquilo
então a gente tem que falar não gostou
vai lá e faz o que a gente ama e para
finalizar não só quero passar essa
mensagem que assina uma coisa pra vocês
que todo mundo que me ver que aprender
mas pra isso eu te pedi um acessório
especial aqui para ensinar
[Música]
olha nós então vamos colocar isso na
cabeça viu ainda não vou ficar aqui só
se repete até porque quando eu coloco
essa coroa na cabeça vou para dois
metros de altura então eu vou pedir pra
todo mundo levantar pra aprender a fazer
o famoso tchauzinho de mim tá bom
o que vocês acham que é uma coisa
simples mas tem todo um truque ó uma
aula de direito a 5 não queira na
cintura mão direita pra cima e pra
mulherada a gente está aqui no balanço
nunca está aqui não pode falar então
aqui ó ó o coxinha na mão a coxinha
aprender e até que eu vou finalizar aqui
com vocês gente muito obrigada pela
atenção e espero que tenha adotado
[Aplausos]
[Música]